-Her album "The Good Witch"
is out June 16th.
Performing
"Lost the Breakup,"
please welcome
Maisie Peters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Got the news
just last month ♪
♪ That I'm exhausting
and you're not in love ♪
♪ Didn't say it
in those words ♪
♪ But I know
how your tone works ♪
♪ You're M.I.A.,
running so free ♪
♪ Calling your ex,
forgetting 'bout me ♪
♪ But I know
you could never ♪
♪ Yeah, I know
you remember ♪
♪ So I'm feeling and I'm dealing
with the heart you broke ♪
♪ While you do press-ups
and repress us ♪
♪ And take off
her clothes, oh ♪
♪ I'm hurting, but I'm certain
it's still true ♪
♪ I'm the best thing
that almost happened to you ♪
♪ I know I'm obsessed and ♪
♪ Right now,
I might be a mess but ♪
♪ One day,
you're gonna wake up ♪
♪ And you'll see,
you lost the breakup ♪
♪ I'll smile and you'll
have to face it ♪
♪ I'm the greatest love
that you wasted ♪
♪ But by then,
I'll be far away ♪
♪ And you'll see,
you lost the breakup ♪
♪ But for now,
I'm out in the dust ♪
♪ Falling apart ♪
♪ Oh, is she just like me? ♪
♪ I reckon ♪
♪ You've got two types,
country and Western ♪
♪ So I'm feeling and I'm dealing
with the heart you broke ♪
♪ While you do press-ups
and repress us ♪
♪ And take off
her clothes, oh ♪
♪ I'm something
if nothing else is true ♪
♪ I'm the best thing
that almost happened to you ♪
♪ I know I'm obsessed and ♪
♪ Right now,
I might be a mess but ♪
♪ One day,
you're gonna wake up ♪
♪ And you'll see,
you lost the breakup ♪
♪ I'll smile and you'll
have to face it ♪
♪ I'm the greatest love
that you wasted ♪
♪ But by then,
I'll be far away ♪
♪ And you'll see,
you lost the breakup ♪
♪♪
♪ You'll see ♪
-♪ You lost the breakup ♪
-♪ You're gonna walk into
some underground bar ♪
♪ You'll see
a pretty little thing ♪
♪ Catching eyes
in the dark ♪
♪ And it's me,
I see you too, I wave ♪
♪ And I'm dancing over to you
in the corner ♪
♪ And you say ♪
♪ "Wow, hey,
it's been forever" ♪
♪ "Do you want to get a drink,
like, together?" ♪
♪ I say,
"I'm kind of busy" ♪
♪ "Like, I'm on 'Fallon'
tonight" ♪
♪ "No, man,
I won the breakup" ♪
♪ I'll smile and you'll
have to face it ♪
♪ I'm the greatest love
that you wasted ♪
♪ But by then,
I'll be far away ♪
♪ And you'll see,
you lost the breakup ♪
♪♪
♪ And you'll see,
you lost the breakup ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]